it is time for this week's
sin city chronicles a weekly look back
at vegas history
and happenings christmas with class that
was the theme of the
grand opening gala of the thomas and
mack it was held on december
16 1983 the event was put together by
steve and elaine nguyen
9 000 people were in attendance to
dedicate the building
which was supposed to feature a reunion
of the rat pack with performances from
frank sinatra dean martin and sammy
davis jr
but sammy became ill and they found a
very
suitable replacement
diana ross who played for one hour now
two days later on december 20th the
thomas and mack
held their first rock concert and that
was
lover boy
and on stage she was so excited to see
loverboy she couldn't contain herself
it's very epic right there
december 18th 1993 was the grand opening
of the mgm grand
we are looking at their first we're
looking at loverboy right now we're
looking at the first commercial of the
mgm grand
now at the time of the opening it was
the largest hotel in the world
the hotel opened three and a half months
early and one of the highlights
was the 33 acre theme park
and that is your sin city chronicles for
this week